[Music]
going back to the earlier days
of your career in particular auditioning
because
nothing fascinates me more than someone
who puts themselves through that and is
able to just
stay focused and even when you get
getting hit with disappointment just
still forging forward so
for the audition process earlier on can
you give me
one high moment and then also one low
moment and then maybe how you overcame
it
yeah um well a high moment i think
well this was one of them um but that's
kind of a boring answer but i'll give
you another one
uh i my first american project a film
called the vow
um that my friend michael susie directed
with rachel mcadams and channing tatum
i was in australia i had just been on a
australian tv show there and i just
wrapped i just finished that and um
that came through and the i put myself
on tape from australia
and i got the roll off tape and i was
beside myself i couldn't believe it um
i hadn't worked in america before i
didn't
know i mean talk about imposter syndrome
i was like what am i doing
next thing i was just on a plane over
here and shooting that movie so
that for me was like definitely one of
the most pivotal moments i mean
well you know that's how i ended up here
essentially and now i live in la so
um i have a lot of gratitude for that
job
um and then low points look i've had a
bunch
it's a brutal industry as everyone in
this business knows
you know there's roles that i've missed
out on there um
i know i was in the mix for oh
um invisible man my but my beautiful
friend harriet dyer got that
that was for uh for the sister all and i
was really disappointed about that but
my friend harriet got it and she's so
amazing and just such a beautiful person
so i was also very happy for her
to get that one i know that was a bummer
and then you know funnily enough i got
this
i think weeks later so i don't think i
could have done this had i done that
which is very interesting too
you